êtes vous favorable à la création d'une
nouvelle collectivité territoriales
alsaciennes
c'est la question centrale de la
consultation citoyenne lancée
aujourd'hui par brigitte klinkert et
frédéric bierry voilà plusieurs mois
qu'il eut haut-rhinois et bas-rhinois
travaille dans le sens d'une réunion des
deux départements
alors qu'au niveau de l'état les signaux
semblent passer au vert on les
départements il étant d'impliquer les
alsaciens et de leur présenter le projet
ce projet c'est de créer une
collectivité à statut particulier
d'alsace qui sera une collectivité
ouverte sur l'espace rhénan une
collectivité aussi qui aura des
compétences supplémentaires
d'une part de la part de la région et
d'autre part de la part de l'état
l'initiative vise à demander aux
alsaciens leur avis sur ce projet mais
aussi à leur permettre d'exprimer des
propositions si la consultation n'a pas
valeur de référendum pour ses
initiateurs on espère qu haut-rhinois et
bas-rhinois seront nombreux à participer
je crois beaucoup à ce que j'appelle
l'intelligence collective dans un
million neuf cent mille têtes il y en a
plus que dans la tête de quelques élus
qui ont réfléchi même si c'est des
projets que nous avons mûrement
réfléchie je suis persuadé que le projet
sera enrichi par les contributions et on
pourra lui donner encore une dimension
plus collective et plus forte afin de
participer rendez vous sur la plateforme
3w expression citoyenne point alsace
pour ceux moins à l'aise avec
l'informatique
un coupon réponse pré timbrée est
disponible dans les derniers magazine
départementaux
[Musique]